everyone sorry this is the first upload
in a little while
I have grand plans what I was going to
be doing over the past couple of weeks
for this channel but unfortunately life
got very busy and term has now however
finished so I think I now have enough
time to do the videos that I want to do
for you guys
but I do realize it's been quite a while
so sorry about that with turn drawing to
a close as is the case with every uni
you get the inevitable rush of
extracurricular activities to finish off
they're big and the term project
whatever it may be and because I do
loads of music that means I've had quite
a few concerts most recently last
weekend I had a fantastic concert with
the University Chapel Choir where we
sang parts of Handel's Messiah when we
sang piece by Kenneth Layton and also
the really famous that Greece it was a
very many
now we recorded it really really well
well I was in charge of it I hope it was
recorded really really well and once
I've got all the resources together
hopefully a recording of one of those
pieces a part of one of those pieces
maybe will go on this channel because
you seem to like the hosts that I put on
before and in terms of the other side of
stuff which I do which is a cappella
singing we had an a cappella ball which
is first time I've ever been done which
was a sort of general societal
get-together and there were some awards
given out including this one apparently
my camera doesn't want to focus on it
but it's the award for best newcomer in
the society I never had an actual trophy
before I've won certificates and stuff
like that and I've won the knowledge
that I've won something but I never
actually want a physical thing so I'm
showing it off because I like I'm quite
proud you know why be doing everyday
though has been working I've been going
into the artists it's kind of nice now
I'm into a routine of going into just an
office 9:00 to 5:00 and doing my job
which at the moment is basically
programming so I can't really how much I
talked about in the last video but
essentially I've been writing programs
in R which is more than computer
language which is normally is for
statistical applications and I've been
taking in some climate data to do some
analysis and outputting it to a process
state but if it kind of sucks because it
means that I will write a program which
will run for say a week but then whilst
it's running they have two other things
I can't just put on
well after my job for me what's cool now
though is that um thanks to my
supervisor I'm in contact with a couple
of people here at your paper in 2002 who
used a computer model which they wrote
of the atmosphere and basically they
demonstrated the point of my research
which is this idea that the stratosphere
affects the troposphere we don't know
what I'm talking about by the way I
actually put up a whole video where I
talk about my research it's a talk I
will link to on the screen right now and
in the description below and they wrote
this computer model and published a
paper on it and it was all very nice
well my supervisor says well we kind of
were interested in that but let's look
at it from a slightly different angle so
they're going to give me their code for
the computer program and I'm gonna delve
in fiddled with a few things and then
run it and that's going to take a couple
of weeks in order to do that though I
need to learn yet another programming
language which I think brings the total
at either six or seven and in addition
to all that work which is going on I I
set myself targets for this year for
this academic year where I sat down and
I worked out where I was now and where I
wanted to be at the end of the first
year of my PhD and it was all stuff like
I want to have done some original
research I want to have either a
publication in print or in preparation
for being printed I want to have gone to
a conference ideally I'd like to
presented a poster a conference and and
also improve my statistical skills and
my programming skills and I had a very
definite set of criteria chance to meet
and in doing that I was researching
which conferences are happening this
year and I'm going to Vienna next month
which is really cool
there's the European geosciences Union
which is sort of all of the jew science
that happens in europe so that could be
both imagery atmospheric science
scientists tectonic activity all all
that kind of stuff and there's a big
meeting every year in this year in
Vienna so I'm going over there with the
other guy home doing a PhD with my
supervisor can't make it and we're going
to go there's a whole day on troposphere
stratosphere coupling and hopefully
beyond spend a little bit of time in the
city so that's definitely gonna be a
video on this channel there's no way in
hell I'm not bringing my camera to that
so where it's going well and singing is
going well and the other
I suppose the other big aspects my life
at the moment is some the campus cinema
I thought it's a little bit about the
campus cinema in the past I mention when
I've gone to see films and stuff and
it's it's like this amazing cinema which
is completely student-run
it's incredibly cheap they put on really
cool films they do a program every time
with all the a she knows it's two
programs intern with all the films in
there so this term we had can you read
that
probably not and now I can't see my face
but um you know in the second half this
term they had breakfast at tiffany's
that had Citizen Kane they had sort of
Manning's playbook Mandela and the most
fun of all was they had the room anybody
who knows what the room is will know how
awesome that is and I bring in campus
cinema up because um I I love film and I
love this cinema and it's unfortunately
under threat because the cinema uses an
35 millimeter projector so that's when
you think of all cinemas I showed this
in a previous video when you think about
cinemas they have these big old reels
that they project through with like a
big lamp behind whereas nowadays big
cinemas use digital projectors and the
campus cinema needs to buy one because
they're just stopping the production of
35 millimeter reels and in order to do
that they need 30,000 pounds so if
they're going on a big fundraiser and
hopefully I'm going to be making a video
about that too which not only will be
raising awareness for the project but it
also give you a chance to see what kind
of see what kind of thing of student
cinema is I didn't even really realize
that campuses had cinemas that weren't
commercially owned when I apply to you
so I think this is a really recall thing
next to how's that I think more people
should know about you know what I'm
actually gonna leave this there though
because I talk way wait wait wait wait
wait way too much in these videos and
they would get really long and there's
no reason for them to be that long so I
do have I'm making it longer I do
however want raise a point and that's
that when I look back at my old videos I
I realized that there are a lot more
comments on you know there were dozens
even hundreds of comments on some my
earlier vlogs and I think it's because I
don't engage with you as I knew my
audience as much as I used to so I I
want to ask you a question I suppose
that I've been thinking about for a
little while I have a theory on but I'm
not gonna tell you where it is because I
don't influence
your answer why do you subscribe to
certain YouTube channels like what
physically makes you go yeah I'm gonna
click Subscribe is it a particular video
is it the the people who are on the
channel is it themes that are present in
the channel I won't know what you guys
think and I think this this should be a
really interesting next video next vlog
that I do which hopefully won't be too
long
we'll have a discussion about this so
leave your answers in the comments
thanks for sticking around and I will
talk to you soon